Mega Pock.
Der Feuer ist wieder am Start.
Oh nein.
Ne, ne, ne. Heute kein Rust.
Heute müsst ihr mir mal helfen,
was zu schreiben.
Ich krieg's nicht auf die Reihe.
Ich hab doch morgen
nochmal als Jahresabschluss
quasi. Ich hab ja eigentlich schon Urlaub.
So bis
Januar. Aber wir haben
morgen noch einen zweitägigen
Teambuilding-Workshop.
Nicht in Frankfurt,
sondern extern irgendwo
im Hotel. Glücklicherweise nicht ganz so weit
weg. Also ich komm da relativ gut
hin und dann wieder weg. Aber
zumindest. Ich hab mir
die letzten paar Wochen
über immer mal
ein paar Sachen aufgeschrieben,
was ich denke, was sinnvoll ist,
bei diesem Teambuilding anzusprechen. Aber
ich bin einfach viel zu
blöd, das irgendwie so
verständlich
zu schreiben, dass man damit
was anfangen kann.
Deswegen hab ich mir gedacht, ich mach das mit dem
Chat zusammen. Was soll da schon schief gehen?
Chatge ist ja
bekanntermaßen absolut sick
im Six-Hat-Mode. Steinharder
lang, ich füll den Zap.
Was muss Community machen? Ich erzähl's gleich nochmal.
Wenn noch mehr Community-ge
am Start ist. In der Zwischenzeit
starte ich mal
meine VM
und upgrade
mal die Packages.
Oh.
Vor allem mal Workstation.
17.5 ist raus.
Ist das nicht schon eine ganze Weile?
17.5?
Das ist doch schon
seit einem Monat oder so.
Okay, was gibt's da eigentlich Neues? Lass mal kurz
checken. Irgendwas, warum sich das lohnt zu updaten?
What's new? New Security
Enhancement.
Control Virtual Machine.
Ja, okay.
Windows
Power Management.
Supports 206.
50. Okay, es hat sich also nichts im Endeffekt geändert, was für mich irgendwie relevant wäre.
Äh, langweilig.
Ja, mach ich. Ja, ja.
Also ich war, heute nicht, aber ich war
heute ist Montag, ne? Ja, ich war gestern.
Gestern Morgen. Gestern Morgen, bevor ich Stream-Gel gemacht hab.
Das hab ich mir, das hab ich mir auch aufgeschrieben, ne? Fix, fix, ob's...
Ja, irgendwann. Demnächst. Keine Ahnung. Wir haben noch so viel Zeug.
Und by the way, warum auch immer ich noch einen Zettel hier auf hab,
auf Klo.
Tap. Ich bin nicht auf Klo.
So, mal kurz Update machen.
Hast du vor, das Update auf Vmware...
Ja. Echt? Wirklich?
Inwiefern?
Warum? Also ich hatte bis jetzt,
ich will nicht sagen noch nie, aber
enorm selten nur Probleme
mit
Vmware Update.
Was war? Was ist kaputt gegangen?
Moin, Chatge.
Okay. So.
Was macht eigentlich
Vmoji
und das
Issue von Discord
Poll Requests?
Haben die das jetzt gemerged?
Wo sind die, wo sind die Discord,
die, die, die Discord-Five-Header?
Äh.
Irgendwie finde ich das nicht mehr, aber Discord,
Discord. Ja doch, der hier ist das doch.
Discord, oder was?
Ja, ja, dann.
Wir brauchen neuen Emoji-Font-Release.
Es ist wichtig.
Es ging.
Also ich hatte bis jetzt noch keine Probleme.
Ich bin gestern Morgen, da war es, glaube ich,
nur 3 Grad oder sogar vielleicht sogar
noch ein bisschen weniger.
Und
ich kenne weder die eine Reaction
noch die andere Reaction, noch
interessiert es mich großartig.
Hast du dir so fancy Laufbekleidung
gekauft?
Definiere fancy.
Ich war mal kurz den ganzen...
Ich, ich, ich.
Ich würde jetzt einfach mal...
Tütüdütütüt.
Tütütüttü.
Definiere fancy.
Also was ich am Start habe, ist je nachdem.
Ein bisschen so nach Temperatur war, meistens.
Ich renne selbst in.
Ich renne selbst bei bei 0-3 Grad noch mit kurzer Hose,
aber da habe ich so,
da habe ich so lange Socken an bisschen das,
was die Fußballspieler anhaben, um ihre Schienbeinschützer zu halten so.
Ähm.
So, so lange.
Socken.
eine kurze Hose, dass im Prinzip nur die Knie raus
gucken, dass es warm genug. Wenn es Minus
wird, wenn es Minus wird, dann lange Hose.
Oder wenn es nass ist, lange Hose.
Ne, aber das wäre auch mal nicht schlecht.
Obenrum, obenrum
habe ich allerdings ein
langes, so ein Funktions
Hemd, also was mit, was schweißdurchlässig
ist. Und dann ziehe ich noch
meistens so eine gelbe Jacke,
also so eine kurze gelbe
Jacke drüber, dass man das halt ordentlich sieht.
Was war mit Twitch heute los?
Toss-Content auf der Startseite
habe ich nicht gesehen.
Was war denn für
Toss-Content auf der Startseite?
Etwa Cocker?
Ich werde das nicht aufmachen,
Chatge.
Was auch immer das ist, ich werde
das nicht aufmachen. Wenn das wirklich
Toss-Content ist, dann
Badestreams. Naja, das ist ja
mittlerweile
so semi-erlaubt.
Bei den Twitch-Regeln blickt doch eh keiner
mehr durch. Die Auslegung
ist doch auch mal so, mal so.
Ja, Links
von Chainlaw sind safe. Wo ist
der eigentlich? Von dem haben wir schon lange nichts mehr gehört.
Gag-Wade, Alter.
Ich konnte es
natürlich wieder nicht lassen. Ich habe
auf dem zweiten Bildschirm doch den
Stream aufgemacht.
So scheiße.
Was bin ich sehend, Mann.
Auf Twitch.
Aber das ist nicht Wonka-Toss.
Die hat ja noch was an.
Wonka-Toss
wäre das,
wenn die nichts mehr anhätte.
Alter.
Was geht auf Twitch ab, Mann?
Tja.
Nichts. Nichts, was verpasst.
Bereit der Aski-Spam
vorzustellen. Da will wieder gebannt werden.
Oh, kann es sein, dass der Chainlaw nichts schreibt,
weil er noch gebannt ist?
Modke.
Ist er vielleicht noch gebannt?
Wir mussten ihn doch letztens zwar wieder...
Aber wir time-outen den noch nur, gell?
Arbeitest du manchmal mit Chat-GPT?
Ja. Wobei, arbeiten ist zu viel gesagt.
Ich lasse mir das wieder gerne manchmal Texte zusammenfassen.
Ist er nicht? Okay.
Texte zusammenfassen oder sowas wie
Ich hab keinen Bock da drauf.
Schreibt mal eine nette Absage oder so.
So Dinger in der Richtung. Das mache ich gerne mit Chat-GPT.
Ansonsten, ja.
Wenn sich's mal anbietet.
Ja.
Also, ich kann euch jetzt erzählen, Chat-GPT.
Was wir mal kurz machen müssen.
Umso schneller wir fertig sind,
umso schneller die Schwarmintelligenz funktioniert,
umso schneller können wir irgendwas anderes machen.
Ich glaube, für Rust habe ich heute keine Gehirnkapazität.
Aber wir können uns vielleicht noch ein 15-Minuten-Video angucken,
wo ich wieder eine Stunde schwätzen muss.
Müssen wir mal gucken.
Irgendwas können wir noch machen.
Aber ich muss das erst mal für morgen vorbereiten.
Also, ich erzähle euch jetzt mal, um was es geht.
Also, ich habe ja eigentlich schon Urlaub.
Bis Januar.
Aber wir haben ab morgen, Dienstag und Mittwoch,
noch einen zweitägigen Teambuilding-Workshop.
Allerdings nicht in Frankfurt,
sondern hier in der Nähe in einem Hotel.
Und ich habe mir jetzt die letzten paar Wochen über immer was aufgeschrieben.
So, wenn mir was auf den Keks gegangen ist.
Oder wenn ich mir gedacht habe,
ey, das Thema könnte man mal in so einem Teambuilding thematisieren.
Das Problem ist,
ich habe wild zusammengeschrieben einfach.
Nur so komplett random.
So quasi vom...
...Kopf in das Textdokument.
Das Problem ist, dass das nicht aussprechbar und verstehbar ist für Außenstehende.
Außer für euch.
Ihr guckt lange genug zu.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das, was ich geschrieben habe,
für euch verständlich ist.
Und da müssen wir jetzt zu jedem...
Also, ich habe insgesamt irgendwie elf Punkte oder so.
Und zu jedem Punkt müssen wir zwei, drei...
Ne, was heißt freiwillig?
Das ist Arbeitszeit.
Ich kriege es bezahlt.
Freiwillig würde ich da nicht hingehen, wenn es nicht bezahlt wird.
Wo hast du bestimmt Twitch-E-Modes reingekriegt?
Ja, ich habe unter anderem kekwait und sowas ab und zu reingeschrieben.
Warum ist die Musik jetzt unterschiedlich laut?
Was ist denn hier schon wieder los?
Ich habe sehr viel gekekwt in der Dings und kekwaited.
Vor allem habe ich kekwaited.
Und also, wir probieren das einfach mal, ja?
Business.txt, ja?
Also, communityge...
Wir machen das mal hier...
Nee, komm, wir machen nicht Notepad, Alter.
Was ist das?
Ich habe kein Visual Studio Code...
Achso, ja gut, ich brauche kein Visual Studio Code, weil ich Visual Studio Code hier habe.
Cocker.
Was auch immer das damit zu tun hat.
Ihr seid bereit, okay.
Nice.
GG Eats.
Wir speichern das mal hier.
Massive.
Fivehead.
Chatge.
Okay.
Also.
Moment.
Chico.
Chico, was ist los?
Okay.
Also, wie gesagt, je schneller wir sind, umso schneller ist das Ganze wieder fertig.
Aber ihr müsst Sixhead, ihr müsst wirklich Sixhead sein.
Das muss irgendwas taugen, ja?
Was da rauskommt.
Ich muss das morgen sagen können und es muss zu so einem Teambuilding-Workshop passen.
Also, ich kann nicht sagen, Gachi, Roll, Kek, Alu oder sowas.
Wobei, das kann ich schon sagen.
Sagen, möglich, reine Aussprache, möglich ist das.
Es wird bloß keiner checken.
Die denken, da wird einer Max labern mit einem komischen Zeug vor sich hin.
Okay.
Also, erster Punkt, den ich mir aufgeschrieben habe.
Ich sage euch erstmal so grob, was ich aufgeschrieben habe.
Da müssen wir irgendwie was draufbauen.
Also, erstes Problem.
Also, wir müssen auch dazu sagen, das dient dazu, um die Zusammenarbeit innerhalb der Gruppe zu verbessern.
Ich bin der Meinung, so schlecht ist die Zusammenarbeit in der Gruppe gar nicht.
Die Probleme, die wir haben, liegen eigentlich nicht so sehr an der Gruppe selber, sondern an den Sachen drumherum.
Unter anderem.
Wird der Workshop durch einen externen Trainer geführt?
Ja.
Also, das erste, was ich mir aufgeschrieben habe, ist, dass, ich lese euch das einfach mal vor, ja.
Und dann müssen wir da irgendeinen Satz draus machen.
Also, wir können auch Chat-GPT, wobei, ich will mein Dokument, da stehen Namen drin und so.
Ich will das Dokument hier nirgendswo reinpisten.
Also, ich habe mir aufgeschrieben, erstens, man rechnet eine Person immer, ich muss das ein bisschen langsamer lesen,
weil ich mir manchmal nicht sicher bin, ob ich was Geheimes reingeschrieben habe oder so.
Also, ich brauche übrigens passende, passende Untermalung dazu.
Also, man rechnet immer eine Person, nein, man rechnet, ich kann auch nicht mal mein eigenes Zeug lesen.
Alter.
Man rechnet eine Person immer 100%, die man verplanen könnte, aber das stimmt nicht.
Mich mit 80% eh mal ausgenommen, weil es so viel Grundrauschen gibt, dass es realistischer ist,
60%, wenn nicht 50% sind.
Ihr stellt vielleicht fest, die Sätze ergeben grammatikalisch keinen Sinn,
aber ich glaube, man versteht, was ich mir da gedacht habe bei.
So.
Zu viele, zu viele, zu viele Meetings.
Ja, ich meine, Meeting gehört ja irgendwie manchmal dazu.
Ich, wie gesagt, ich habe das, ich habe das direkt Kopf...
Text gedumpt.
Ich habe mir gedacht, ich schreibe das irgendwann nochmal ordentlich, ja.
So.
Ähm.
Ja, das ist schön, aber das wird nicht gesehen und mit eingerechnet.
Ich kann am Tag nur 50% arbeiten, weil 50% irgendwas anderes sind.
Ich muss doch jetzt kein Screenshot vom Kalender zeigen.
So.
Das ist, das ist das Erste, was ich mir aufgeschrieben habe.
Also, ich würde mal sagen,
den Punkt können wir zusammenfassen mit zu vielen Meetings und...
Also, es sei denn...
Moment, es geht, es geht ja noch weiter.
Es geht ja noch weiter.
Ich habe noch mehr dazu aufgeschrieben.
Okay.
Das ist free money.
Das stimmt, das stimmt.
Ich habe auch überhaupt keine Probleme mit Meetings.
Ich habe das Problem, dass es...
Okay, ich erkläre das einfach mal, was ich meine.
Ja.
Ähm.
Das finde ich ist eine gute, das ist eine gute Sache.
Das ist eine gute Sache, ja.
Das ist eine gute...
Chat, Chat.
Pfeifert, ja.
Das ist, das ist eine gute, gute Frage.
Also, was ich meine ist Folgendes.
Ich habe überhaupt gar keine Probleme, wenn gemietet wird.
Wenn, ich mache ich ja auch.
Wenn die Firma will, dass man mietet und die das bezahlen, dann miete ich auch.
Das, was ich doof finde, finde ist...
Eigentlich ist zu viele Meetings ist falsch.
Das stimmt nicht.
Ich habe überhaupt kein Problem mit zu vielen Meetings.
Was mir nicht gefällt ist, dass 100% der Leute die Zeit geplant wird,
von denen 100% sind...
Allerdings bloß 50% was, wo man machen kann.
Versteht ihr?
Versteht ihr, was ich meine?
Das kennt doch wahrscheinlich jeder von euch.
Oder die, oder viele von euch kennen das wahrscheinlich.
Ja, das so irgendwie, so, so in der Richtung, ja.
Also, sag mal.
Das, das ist, das ist aber, das...
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Das, das lasse ich mal hier drinnen.
Also, ich würde sagen, zu viele Meetings ist vielleicht...
Warte mal, Fragezeichen dahinter.
Also, eigentlich, eigentliches Problem ist doch eigentlich, man rächt nicht, wenn man...
Man rechnet eine Person gleich, gleich...
Alter, ich kann es gar nicht.
Gleich 100%
Außer mich mit 80.
Lul.
Ich kann kein normales Deutsch mehr schreiben.
Das ist unmöglich.
Man rechnet eine Person gleich 100%.
Und das erwarten dann zum Beispiel die Projekte auch.
Okay, ja.
Versteht man, versteht man ja was gemein ist.
Aber, durch das ganze Grundrauschen...
Und Meetings...
Und...
Ja, äh...
Overhead...
Ploat...
Wir schreiben einfach...
Sind es am Ende nur 50-60%.
Okay.
Ich glaube...
Das ist gut.
Das...
Das kann man, denke ich, so lassen.
So, dann habe ich mir noch was dazu aufgeschrieben.
Und zwar...
Also, ich würde gerne diesen Punkt überleiten.
Zu was anderem.
Aber davor...
Ich habe mir noch ein bisschen mehr dazu aufgeschrieben.
Und zwar...
So, bei uns gehen nämlich irgendwann auch Leute in Rente.
Und da frage ich mich, wie das dann werden soll.
Ein weiterer Punkt ist...
Wir können...
Genau.
Das muss auch noch rein, Chat.
Das muss auch noch rein.
Wissenstransfer, sehr gut.
Wissenstransfer...
Hält...
Flach...
Hält oft...
Zum Beispiel...
Weekly...
Wir haben Weekly so...
Ja...
Wie nennt man das?
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das richtig heißt bei uns.
Wir haben so einen wöchentlichen Termin...
Wo die Leute...
Können aus ihrem Bereich...
Damit die anderen das mitkriegen...
Ähm...
Findet fast nie statt.
Moment, das denkt...
Moment, denkt der, das ist...
Alter, der denkt, das ist ein Kubernetes-Manifest.
Ja, ich finde, das sieht auch schon...
Ganz hart aus am Kubernetes-Manifest, Mann.
Außerdem ist das kein Jammel.
Das ist einfach...
Markdown.
Ja...
So, und dann...
Und dann habe ich hier noch aufgeschrieben...
Für die Frage...
Ich antizipiere nämlich schon...
Dass...
Die Frage kommt...
Die Frage wird kommen...
Und vielleicht kennt ihr diese Frage auch...
Wenn man so Punkte bringt, wird dann die Frage kommen...
Macht es denn Sinn...
An allem teilzunehmen?
Und da muss man halt ganz klar sagen...
Potenziell schon...
Man weiß ja die genauen Inhalte nicht...
Und es kann ja gut sein...
Dass es wichtige Infos gibt...
Und man bei manchen Punkten...
Was zu sagen will...
Und wenn man dann nicht hingeht...
Heißt es am Ende...
Ja, wärst du da gewesen, da wurde das doch gesagt...
Ja...
Das muss ich auch noch irgendwie...
Hier aufnehmen...
Da machen wir mal 1.1 raus...
Sind alle...
Meetings sinnvoll?
Nein, aber...
Das weiß man ja vorher nicht...
Wir haben letztens darüber gesprochen...
Ob wir einen Tunneltag einbauen...
Einen Tag ohne Meetings...
Ja...
Ja, das wäre vielleicht auch nicht verkehrt...
Ne, so schlimm ist das nicht...
Ne, ne, ne, so schlimm ist das nicht...
Das hat sich jetzt schlimmer angehört, als es ist...
Aber ich mein...
Es ist doch nachvollziehbar...
Wenn man sagt...
Ich hab zu viele Meetings...
Ich sag jetzt einfach mal ein paar davon ab...
Dass dann im Endeffekt doch was wichtiges gesagt wird...
Das ist auch so ein Punkt...
Bei den meisten Meetings...
Wird tatsächlich...
Also...
Nicht explizit was festgehalten, sondern...
Es werden danach, wenn die Leute dran denken...
Irgendwelche Tickets draus generiert oder nicht...
Ich find das aber auch gut...
Ganz ehrlich...
Protokolle sind komplett useless...
Protokolle guckt niemand rein...
Und jeder ist abgefuckt, wenn er sie schreiben muss...
Wenn es wirklich wichtige Sachen gibt...
Das ist was anderes...
Aber dieses normale 0815...
Ähm...
Ich hab schon gesehen, dass hier wieder ein Samba-Share weg ist...
Oder sowas...
Das musste nirgendswo schriftlich festhalten...
Nein, nein, nein, nein...
Kein Protokoll...
Ja, hab ich aber nicht auf die Reihe gekriegt...
Kein Protokoll, ich hasse Protokolle...
Das macht niemand...
In der Theorie klingt es immer gut...
Seriously Leute, Hand aufs Herz...
Wer von euch...
Guckt sich...
Team-Protokolle, also Team-Meeting-Protokolle an...
Wenn er nicht da war?
...
Guckt sie sich an...
Wir machen mal...
Wir machen mal ne Abstimmung...
Ich sag die Wenigsten...
Die Wenigen gucken sich das an...
Guckt ihr in...
...
... ...
Sachen. Sind ja nicht immer die gleichen
Leute dabei. Das ist immer ganz unterschiedlich.
Und man muss sagen, bei
ungefähr der Hälfte, würde ich sagen.
Bei ungefähr der Hälfte haben wir
eine Agenda, bei ungefähr der Hälfte
nicht.
Das sind aber auch
oftmal Sachen, die kann man...
Das ist sehr schwierig,
da irgendwelche Agendas...
Weil wer soll das machen? Das ist ja schon wieder das nächste Problem.
Ich habe morgen
ein Teambuilding-Workshop und ich dachte mir, anstatt
dass wir irgendwelche blöden
Gruppenspielchen machen, so irgendwie
wie wir spielen Topfschlagen
oder verstecken uns im Wald
oder machen eine Schnitzeljagd, also was auch immer
sich dann so Trainer so tolle Sachen ausdenken.
Habe ich gesagt, ich dachte ich mir so,
ich bringe mal ein paar Themen mit,
die wirklich was bringen würden, drüber zu
reden.
Ich würde sagen,
den ersten Punkt haben wir
jetzt.
Jetzt kommen wir
zum nächsten Punkt.
Und das ist auch was,
was mich übelst
nervt. Und zwar,
wenn man dann
halb afk...
So.
Wenn man dann mal mit Leuten
über irgendwas mietet,
wie gesagt, da kommt das eine
zum anderen. Wenn man dann mal
wirklich mit Leuten über irgendwas mietet, was ich
für wichtig halte, oder
wo es um irgendwas geht, wo man gerade dran
arbeitet oder so, da sind die Leute
eben genau wegen diesem Punkt hier
halb afk,
weil sie halb im Meeting sind und halb am
Arbeiten.
Halb am Mieten, halb
am Arbeiten.
Ja.
Und das ist
das, da gibt es dann,
das ist super nervig.
Dann sagt irgendjemand was, oder du
sagst es, und dann
fragt man dann so nach dem Motto,
ja hier Peter, was sagst
du dazu? Und dann hörst du so richtig
tick, tick,
tick, und irgendwie so nach drei Sekunden,
vier Sekunden unmutet,
sich Peter dann, und sagt dann so,
äh, ja, wie war nochmal die Frage?
So, das nervt mich so, das zieht
die Sache nochmal unnötig in die Länge.
Und ich bin mir sicher, das liegt daran,
das liegt daran, weil die Leute
100% verplant sind, 100% machen,
oder, ja, zumindest das Gefühl
haben, 100% machen zu müssen,
aber sie sind
in irgendwelchen Meetings und sind,
sie machen nichts Halbes und nichts Ganzes.
Ich mach das übrigens
auch so, ja, ja, ja, ich mach das
auch so. Christian, danke schön für den Sub.
Sucked. So.
Das reicht eigentlich,
wenn man das so schreibt.
Du hast Text-to-Speech mitlaufen lassen.
Das ist auch eine gute Idee.
Das ist auch eine gute Idee. So. Also, das ist,
das ist mein nächster Punkt. Halb AFK
während Call, halb Amiten, halb,
aber nichts Halbes und nichts Ganzes.
Ja, und das liegt,
das liegt an Punkt 1.
Sag ich euch ganz klar.
Das ist, das ist, das ist echt das Problem.
Aus meiner Sicht, ja.
Dann kann ich, da kann ich schon mal die Hälfte
löschen aus meinem Textdokument, da weiß ich.
Da hab ich das hier schon.
So. Nächster Punkt. Dritter Punkt.
Dadurch,
dass, wie gesagt, da kommt, ohne Scheiß,
da kommt eins, eins zum anderen.
Durch diese ganzen Sachen,
dadurch, dass auch Wissenstransfer
oft flach fällt und
unser Weekly-Austausch-Things oftmals nicht
stattfindet, ist drittens,
ist auch so ein Punkt, es sind
sehr viele Einzelkämpfer.
Sehr viele Einzelkämpfer.
Unterwegs, jeder
beschäftigt sich.
Die Musik,
Spooky, Spooky-Musik
passt ja auch dazu.
Ja, das ist auch nervig.
Nee, ich hab morgen Teambuilding-Workshop
und ich dachte mir, anstatt bevor wir irgendwelche blöden
Gruppenspielchen machen, bring ich mal ein paar
Sachen mit, die man wirklich
mal drüber reden könnte, ja.
Nee, nee, das ist, das ist gar nicht so.
Das, das ist wirklich nicht so.
Bei uns, wir haben, wir haben im Team sehr viele Leute,
die sagen alle sehr gerne was und sind immer auch
der Meinung, dass ihre Sache, ich ja auch,
ich bin ja auch so schlimm, ja, dass ihre Sache,
ähm,
das all sich wahre ist, so, aber
die sind schon
hilfsbereit untereinander. Das kann man, das, also
es liegt nicht daran, dass die Leute sich nicht
abkönnen oder nicht miteinander arbeiten wollen.
Ja, wenn sie nicht
wollen, ist auch gut,
dann sollen sie halt irgendwelche komischen Gruppenspielchen
machen, irgendwelche komischen Gruppenspielchen
machen, aber
dann muss man sich nicht wundern, wenn das nicht gut ist.
Wenn es nix bringt, ja.
Aber gerade sowas, dass wir sehr
viele Einzelkämpfer haben,
das ist was, ich denke,
das ist genau richtig bei einem
Teambuilding-Workshop. Das liegt aber auch
genau da dran. Das liegt
zum größten Teil da dran.
Und ich hab mir dazu aufgeschrieben,
so,
wir haben sehr viele Einzelkämpfer,
ich auch, ich auch,
ich auch.
Das, das ist ein guter Punkt.
Es sind alle da.
Also alle.
Das, das, das, das, das schreibe ich mal auf.
Das schreibe ich mal auf, das ist ein guter
Punkt, Chat. Es ist alle, also
es sind, es sind bis auf Teamleiter-Ebene.
Also, die Leute im Team
und der Chef sind da.
Also, man kann da schon sinnvollerweise
was besprechen, ja.
So, also, was ich, was ich mir
aufgeschrieben hab zu, zu dem Thema,
den hätte ich erst recht nicht
wieder geholt. Den hätte ich erst recht nicht wieder
geholt. Den hätte ich mir lieber irgendein Solaris
Consultant oder so bestellt,
für, für ein halbes Jahr.
Nämlich.
Also, wir müssen mal
vorwärts, Leute, wir kommen überhaupt nicht,
also, wir haben, wir haben sehr viele Einzelkämpfer
und dazu habe ich mir
aufgeschrieben, das liegt
nicht daran, dass wir irgendwie
uns nicht abkönnen untereinander
und, dass man quasi
erstmal Schnitzeljagd im Wald machen muss,
damit wir uns, damit, damit wir
uns, ähm,
alle wieder mögen. Das ist, das ist
eigentlich Blödsinn. Ähm,
das liegt einfach so an den, an den
unterschiedlichen Aufgaben
und nicht daran, dass die Leute nichts
miteinander zu tun haben wollen.
Weiß nicht, wie man das, das,
wie, wie könnte man das ordentlich begründen?
Also, so, wenn ich, also,
was ich erlebt hab, ist, wenn die Leute
miteinander sich mal hinsetzen und was machen,
dann
funktioniert das wunderbar.
Nur meistens kommt es nicht dazu.
Aber das liegt nicht daran,
weil die Leute sich nicht abkönnen.
Das, das,
das liegt eigentlich eher daran,
weil sich halt jeder um seinen eigenen Scheiß kümmern muss.
Ja, dann ist Einzelkämpfer
das falsche Wort.
Isolierte Arbeits...
Das klingt super
High-IQ-mäßig. Können wir das auch
irgendwie, können wir das irgendwie so beschreiben, dass es
jeder versteht? Nein, nein,
das trifft's auch nicht.
Ist sie los? Ja, ist sie...
Das ist, das ist, das ist ganz gut.
Isolierte. Ja, wir schreiben.
Liegt nicht daran,
dass die Leute kein...
sich...
nicht abkönnen.
Sondern...
sowas, sowas in der Richtung. Ja, das trifft's.
Isolierte
Silos.
Richtig, das ist gut, das ist gut.
Es ist schneller, das Ding selbst zu machen,
als sich zusammen...
als sich zusammenzusetzen, weil alle überlastet sind.
Ähm...
Wissens...
Transfer, schreiben wir da nochmal hin.
Okay? Perfekt, reicht. Dritter Punkt erledigt.
Dritter Punkt erledigt. Das ist okay.
Das ist gut.
Genau das trifft's. Das wird dann nämlich nicht gemacht,
weil's einfach schneller ist,
derjenige, der sich schon damit auskennt,
auskennt,
sich zusammenzusetzen. Ja, ja, ja.
Überlastet ist aber das Falschwort.
Weil, ja doch. Weil, weil...
Ja, ja, ja. Komm, komm.
Lassen wir's mal so stehen. Lassen wir's mal so stehen.
Und alle
mit ihrem eigenen Kram.
So, nennen wir's mal so.
Vielleicht kann man das noch ein bisschen...
Viertens. Wir sind...
Wir sind kein Anwendungsentwicklerteam.
Ja, das bräuchten wir eh.
Ich bin mal gespannt. Bei uns gehen demnächst auch ein paar Leute in Rente.
Die waren früher, by the way, auch
Solaris-Admins.
Und im eigenen
Mikrokosmos. Das ist auch eine sehr
schöne Umschreibung. Das find ich gut.
Ja. Siehste, Chat.
Es hat sich...
Es hat sich schon wieder gelohnt,
dass ihr am Start seid.
Im eigenen Mikrokosmos.
Das ist Sixthead-Formulierung.
Das ist so typische...
Im eigenen Mikrokosmos. Das ist so richtige...
Das könnte so ein richtiger Manager-Bullshit-Satz sein.
Find ich, find ich gut.
Ich glaub, ich hab FFZ hier nicht. Ah, doch, ne.
Sind bei dir auch Devs im Team?
Nein.
Die ist einfach zur Community
ge...
Ja, wir haben auch Doku-Dinger.
Das Problem ist nur, dass halt jeder
sein Zeug... Also erstens.
OneNote. Ich hasse OneNote.
Die Suche von OneNote
ist einfach Schrott.
Kannst keine Sub-String suchen, ist einfach...
Mir fällt da kein nettes Wort für.
Ist einfach Dreck.
Confluence-Suche
ist auch Kacke.
Also.
Das Ding ist.
OneNote-Page für alles und jeden.
Dann findest du auch alles und jedes
wieder.
Okay. Nächster Punkt. Chat geht.
Sonst wird das nichts. Nächster Punkt.
Weiß ich nicht, ob wir den reinschreiben sollten.
Ich glaub, der hat im Teambuilding
nix zu tun. Ist aber auch ein Punkt, den ich mir
aufgeschrieben hab. Aber ich glaube,
das, ähm,
lassen wir weg. Ich hab
geschrieben, die Komplexität
ist zu hoch. Entweder du weißt
es oder bist fünf Jahre plus
dabei und hast es mal gehört
und weißt, in welchem der hundert
Doku-Systeme man suchen muss
oder man hat verloren.
Ähm.
Doku ist ja
schön und gut.
Aber man hat halt trotzdem keine Ahnung, wo
und in welchem System. Naja, das hat mit
Teambuilding nix zu tun. Das lassen wir weg.
So. Dann ist mir ein Punkt aufgefallen.
Der, find ich, der hat halt, der
den müsste man eigentlich mal im Teambuilding
ansprechen, weil das hab ich schon
von einigen Leuten gesehen. Gerade von
Leuten, die schon länger dabei sind.
Die haben eine gewisse
nervige
Art
zu
...
Leute in ihre Richtung zu
ähm
die Leute dazu zu drängen, das zu machen, was sie
wollen. Ich kann das nicht anders so erzählen.
Das trifft nicht wirklich mein Team direkt.
Also auch, da haben wir auch ein paar Leute,
die sowas in der Richtung machen, aber
das ist so ein Ding, das hab ich allgemein,
das hab ich allgemein schon erlebt.
Also, zum Beispiel, ich, mal, mal
nicht nörgeln, ich, ich, mal ein Beispiel.
Mal ein Beispiel, ja. Nichts,
was passiert ist, sondern
das denk ich mir jetzt aus, ja.
Also, zum Beispiel,
wenn man irgendwie drüber redet,
Moment.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Also, was ich meine ist folgendes.
Also, stellt euch mal vor,
ähm, irgendein Server ist
kaputt.
Einer von den Systemen, die ihr nicht kennt, weil ihr nicht
für zuständig seid, ja.
Aber, ihr loggt euch trotzdem mal drauf ein
und guckt
und danach in irgendeinem Daily
oder so, redet ihr da drüber.
Und dann gibt es Leute,
die ungefähr, also,
dann sagt man, okay, ey, ich war auf dem
System eingeloggt, aber,
also, an den üblichen Stellen war
nix und
ich konnt auf, ich konnt auf
die Schnelle nicht sehen, was, was der, was der
Server für Probleme hat. So.
Stellt euch, stellt euch vor, sagt ihr, sagt ihr, ja.
Und dann gibt es Leute, die antworten
da drauf sowas wie,
ja, aber du hast doch
sicher in dem und dem System
reingeschaut.
Also hast du doch sicher auch gesehen,
dass das und das das Problem ist.
Kennt ihr
das? Leute, die einem mit der
Frage, was in Mund, da gibt
es auch ein Wort für, da gibt es auch ein Wort
für. Mir fällt's grad nicht ein.
Es geht, es geht, das
ist so ne Taktik, ja, das
ist, das ist, ja, genau das meine
ich, ja, genau das meine ich. Dass man den
Leuten versucht, was
quasi, egal wie sie
drauf antworten,
das in den Mund zu legen,
dass sie sich entweder direkt
verteidigen müssen, oder,
aber das ist nicht so schlimm, das ist so ganz,
aber es gibt ein paar Leute, die haben da echt
so den Hang dazu.
Das ist aber, genau, das, das ist gut.
Das, das trifft's ganz gut, das,
ich finde, da sollte man sich mal echt
an die eigene Nase fragen, fassen, wie was
ankommt, ja.
Das sollte man sich so allgemein fragen.
Ich versuch, ich mach sowas auch manchmal,
ja, aber,
ich, ich, ich versuch mich,
ich versuch mich bei sowas immer
ein bisschen zusammenzureißen, mir zu überlegen,
okay,
wie, wie würdest, wie würdest,
wie würdest du das finden, wenn einer sowas,
ich mein, klappt trotzdem nicht, ja, ich,
nervt bestimmt auch genug, Leute.
Ja, das kann man so nicht, das kann man so nicht
das sagen, das ist viel zu hart,
aber,
ja, das, das, da brauch ich ein gutes Beispiel für,
ja.
Ohne Mist, also,
ich hab mit den Leuten kein, ich hab mit, nicht ein,
es gibt ein paar Leute, die sind, ja,
ich weiß, ich geh auch manchen auf den Keks,
es gibt ein paar, die sind ein bisschen mehr oder weniger nervig,
aber ich hab mit keinem irgendwie
ein großartiges Problem. Das hatte ich auf der alten Arbeit
mehr, da gab's Leute, die haben mich richtig abgefuckt.
Im Großen und Ganzen ist das echt
meckern auf hohem Niveau, die sind
eigentlich auch projektübergreifend so eigentlich
zum größten Teil wirklich nett, die Leute.
Die haben halt so ihre Eigenheiten,
aber ganz ehrlich, IT-Leute haben alle
ihre Eigenheiten.
Einfach nicht drauf eingehen?
Ne, das Beste, was man
machen kann, aus meiner, meiner Meinung nach, weil,
wenn man das erkennt, ist, direkt zu
sagen, dass du dann sagst,
ja, okay, was soll ich
denn da drauf jetzt antworten, ja?
So wie du das darstellst,
ja, hätte man's doch, hätte man's wissen müssen, oder
wie? Also, ich glaube, es ist gar, es ist,
es macht keinen Sinn, direkt da drauf einzugehen
und das anzunehmen, was der, was
der, was, was man quasi im Mund gelegt
kriegt, sondern man muss direkt sagen,
ähm, dass
das quasi
einem was im Mund liegt, was, was so nicht gesagt wurde.
Dann, dann ist auch gut.
Ja. Ja, es, es gibt,
also, wir müssen, wir müssen auch nochmal hier was
nachher ist man immer
schlauer, ja?
So nach dem Motto,
so, warum hast du
heut, warum hast du
am Sonntag
nicht die, nicht
die richtigen
Lottozahlen getippt?
So.
So nach dem Motto,
heute weiß man sie ja.
So, wisst ihr, also, so nach dem Motto,
ja, man hat eine halbe Stunde drüber geredet,
aber es ist halt ein Unterschied,
ob man an einem System sitzt, was gerade kaputt
ist und alle sind am Schreien,
oder ob man zwei Stunden Zeit hat,
sich da drüber Gedanken zu machen.
Ja, sowas.
Okay, ähm,
und am Ende müssen wir uns noch die Top-Punkte
raussuchen, die, die ich, weil ich glaube
nicht, dass ich alle Sachen, also viel Zeit ist da
gar nicht. So.
Das nächste, das nächste finde ich auch,
das nächste ist auch so ein Ding,
das ist glaube ich eher so mit den Leuten, wo ich,
wo ich, äh,
mehr zusammenarbeite, der Fall,
wir zerdiskutieren enorm
viel und lassen uns
super leicht
sidetracken. Ihr kennt mich, ich bin
der Meisterside-Sidetracker, kennt
sich der, ja, ja, haben wir auch schon benutzt hier
im Stream sogar.
Ja, äh, wir
zerdiskutieren
vieles
und lassen
uns super leicht
sidetracken. Beispiel,
Beispiel.
Wir haben ein Daily, das ist für 15
Minuten angesetzt.
Derjenige, der als erstes sein
Thema sagen kann,
hat gewonnen. Da wird 15
Minuten dann drüber diskutiert.
Und das ist eigentlich nicht Sinn und Zweck der Sache.
Derjenige, der im
Daily anfangen darf,
äh, erst
was sagt,
carpet das Daily. Schreiben wir es mal sowas,
schreiben wir es mal ungefähr so hin. Ja.
Ich meine dazu, dazu gibt's
kein, die Lösung dazu ist ganz
einfach. Die Lösung dazu ist
ganz einfach, ähm,
schieben wir es
nach Daily.
Da gibt's wieder Leute, die sagen, ey, aber das
gehört doch zum Daily dazu. Da
muss man sich halt mal was überlegen.
Nee, kannst du nicht, kannst du nicht immer machen,
ja. Daily geht's ja grad
Oh.
Nee, das ist zu, zu over,
zu overkill.
Ich mag Protokolle
auch nicht. Nee.
Nö, nö, nö, nö. Das ist ja auch noch so
ein Punkt, dass ich gefühlt meinen Chef
dreimal, dreimal gesprochen hab, seitdem
er Chef ist, so. Ja.
Ich schreib einfach nur mal alles auf, was
mir so einfällt. Wir müssen es da noch ein bisschen,
wir brauchen da noch die Top Points
da draus, die man, die man
also, wir, also wir
diskutieren vieles und lassen es mega leicht
sidetracken. Ja.
Und das ist auch noch so ein Punkt,
alle reden
durcheinander.
Ähm, also das,
das ist halt auch so ein Ding, wenn was ist,
wo alle der Meinung sind, was zu sagen
zu können, dann sagen alle gleichzeitig was.
Das ist ganz, das ist ganz schrecklich.
Und die hören dann auch nicht auf.
Normalerweise ist es ja so,
wenn jetzt, wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel
sag, äh, chatkill,
ich, ich finde lulwee
deutlich besser als keckwee. So, da könnt ihr
sagen, 20 Leute, nein Max, das stimmt nicht.
Alle gleichzeitig. Aber sobald,
sobald dann, irgendwie,
normalerweise einigt man sich da so
ungeschrieben dann da drauf,
wer denn jetzt weitermachen darf.
Ja, entweder der, der am lautesten
schreit oder der, der am
hartnäckigsten ist oder irgendwas.
Aber, die schwätzen
dann teilweise mit 4 Mann
durcheinander für 10 Minuten. Das ist ganz
schrecklich, man. Ja.
Hehehe.
Redeball, ja.
So, und dazu würde ich sagen, immer
dran denken, wir
reden über Teams, das heißt
1, 2, 6, lag.
Das muss man
nämlich mal dazu sagen. Leute, die
Online-Spiele-Erfahrungen haben, wissen das eigentlich,
wie man, äh, äh,
in, in Discord und Teams und
früher war es noch Teamspeak
und sowas ordentlich reden kann, ohne
dass man sich ins Wort fällt, aber irgendwie und
obwohl ich weiß, dass da ein paar Leute Online-Spiele-Erfahrungen
haben aus meinem Team, kriegen sie es oftmals nicht
richtig hin. Wobei, doch.
Der eine, von dem ich definitiv weiß,
oder auch die zwei, von denen ich es definitiv weiß, die kriegen es hin.
So, dann machen wir das doch mal weg.
So, und
das ist eine Sache, die sag ich jetzt hier,
die werde ich dann nicht zur Sprache bringen,
aber das ist auch so ein Ding. Bei uns hat jeder
so ein bisschen so seine Lieblingsthemen, worüber
er redet. Und die ziehen
das teilweise auch ganz knallhart durch,
ja. Der eine kommt immer
mit so Dingern, also,
ich hab ja auch schon meinen Spruch, der, der immer
kommt, ja. Also, bei uns ist das,
bei uns ist das meistens so,
der, also, es geht, es geht um
irgendein Thema, ja. Und dann
kommen dann so, so super random
Einwürfe, so nach dem Motto,
was weiß ich, stellt euch mal vor,
ich würde euch jetzt erzählen,
ja, es gibt Probleme
mit der, mit der
äh, Storage Replizierung
in der Google Cloud, so.
Das ist einfach mal ein fiktives Beispiel.
Formless Beastmore, danke schön für den Sub.
Ja, zum Beispiel. Ja, stellt euch vor,
ihr könntet jetzt zugucken, so bei
unserem Team-Meeting, und ich würde erzählen,
ja, Leute, übrigens, es gibt gerade
Probleme bei der Storage Replikation,
in Google. So, dann kommt
der Erste mit sowas ganz
wirrem um die Ecke
und sagt, ja, hält Google
dann auch den Abstand zwischen ihren Rechenzentren
ein? Und dann denkst du dir so,
was?
Was zum Teufel hat das damit
zu tun?
Das ist nicht wirklich
off-topic, aber auch nicht wirklich
on-topic. So,
dann kommt der Nächste um die Ecke,
ähm, das wurde doch auf
Meeting YYZ vor zwei Monaten
mal so besprochen, und
die dritte Fußnote
von unten sagt, dass man das an passender
Stelle anbringen soll. Der Nächste
ist AFK am Tippen, weil er gerade
eigentlich was arbeiten muss. Der Nächste kommt
um die Ecke und sagt, ja, mach das bloß nicht
auf Ubuntu, das ist nicht supported.
Und dann komm ich um die Ecke und sag, Jungs, wir
sollten jetzt langsam mal anfangen.
So laufen
total oft unsere Dailies, Mann.
So richtig random
Zeug.
Das ist echt
nicht richtig off-topic,
aber auch
nicht richtig
on-topic.
So,
machen wir das mal weiter.
Genau, das
eins, eins, genau eins, was ich hier,
was ich gut fände, so als
Lösung, als Lösung dafür,
ja, ähm,
es wäre nice,
wenn
sich
alle bei Fragen
auf den Kern
konzentrieren würden.
Ähm,
und
ich weiß nicht, wie ich das schreiben soll, Leute.
Ich hab den Eindruck, und ich mach
sowas auch manchmal, es ist wie gesagt,
ich nehme mich bei den ganzen Sachen nicht aus,
ich hab so den Eindruck,
ähm, dass Leute
absichtlich
das falsch verstehen,
um dann doch wieder ihr
Thema ansprechen zu können.
Wisst ihr, wie ich mein? Also,
also, man weiß doch, wie es gemeint ist.
Man weiß doch, okay, Beispiel, Beispiel,
Beispiel, ähm,
wenn ich euch
jetzt sage,
wie gesagt, auch wieder ausgedacht,
wenn ich euch jetzt sage, hey Leute,
es
gab eine
Monitoring-Meldung,
daraufhin
haben wir
Service XY neu gestartet,
und dann kam es
zu zwei Folgefehlern.
Und jetzt müssen
wir mal gucken, warum das Monitoring so komische
Dinger macht. So.
Und dann kommt dann
nicht irgendwie der Einwand, okay,
ähm, was könnte mit dem
Monitoring verkehrt sein? Nein, dann kommt dann,
da kommt dann der Hinweis,
ähm, das war doch gar kein
Folgefehler, das war doch eine Folgemeldung.
Versteht ihr, sowas
mein ich. Sowas mein ich. Also,
äh, wäre es nicht, wäre
es nicht sinnvoll,
wenn
jemand eine Frage stellt, wenn jemand was
sagt, den,
den
Kern dessen
zu
sich Mühe zu
geben, den Kern einer Frage
zu erkennen.
Ne, das ist doch nicht mal böse
gemeint, glaube ich, an der Stelle.
Ah, das finde ich,
finde ich gut, ja.
Ja, also so quasi
versuchen,
den, ähm,
also versuchen, den Kern zu erkennen, ja,
den Kern zu erkennen,
so, ich weiß nicht, wie ich es anders, wie ich es anders
beschreiben soll, weil, seriously,
es ist
eigentlich jedem klar, was gemeint ist.
Es ist vollkommen egal, ob man
Folgemeldung oder Folgefehler sagt. Es ist
vollkommen klar, was gemeint ist.
Ja, so, schreiben wir es mal so. Ne, wir müssen
weitermachen, Chat, sonst wäre das nix.
Ähm,
Korinne, die Kacke.
Ja, das würde ich so nicht schreiben.
Ja, aber so versuchen, den Kern zu erkennen.
Ich erinnere, ich
erwische mich auch manchmal dabei,
dass, wenn einer was sagt, wenn es ein Thema ist,
wozu ich Ahnung habe, dass ich dann unbedingt nochmal
erwähnen muss, dass ich mich damit auch auskenne, oder
irgendwas in der Richtung, ja, also,
es ist, es ist so. Also versuchen,
versuchen quasi so den Kern zu erkennen
und darauf zu konzentrieren, weil dann geht es auch schneller.
Was machen wir gerade? Wir haben,
ich habe morgen ein zweitägiges Teambuilding
und ich wollte mir ein paar Punkte, ich habe mir so eine
random Liste mit Punkten aufgeschrieben
und ich wollte da mal was, was
verarbeitbares draus machen.
Ich dachte mir, der high IQ Chat kann mir
dabei helfen und hat, funktioniert ja auch
gut, funktioniert ja auch gut, ja.
Also, das finde ich ganz gut.
So, nächster, nächster Punkt.
Äh, wir ziehen Sachen zu
lang, äh, manchmal geht es 30
Minuten, na gut, das habe ich, das habe ich ja hier oben schon.
Das, das habe ich ja hier schon, wie das
viele, vieles, vieles diskutieren und super leicht
sidetracken lassen. Das habe ich ja schon.
Ähm,
hier habe ich, ich habe es, Leute, ich habe es viel
besser aufgeschrieben schon in meinem Dokument, was ich
hier sagen wollte und zwar, ich habe mir
aufgeschrieben, versuchen die
Essenz zu verstehen von dem, was
gesagt wird
und, ähm,
und genau, ich habe es, ich habe es doch genau
richtig schon aufgeschrieben. Ich habe mir hier aufgeschrieben,
versuchen die Essenz zu verstehen
von dem, was gesagt wird und wenn
einer zwei Minuten, was
komplexes erzählt, nicht
zehn Minuten über eine falsche
Sache, die er vielleicht gesagt hat,
ähm,
sich auslassen.
Ja, das, das trifft es auch,
es trifft es auch eigentlich ganz gut.
Schreiben wir das nochmal anders her.
Versuchen die
Essenz des
Gesagten zu verstehen,
zum Beispiel jemand erzählt
zwei Minuten was
komplexes, dann
muss man nicht zehn Minuten
über ein falsches
Wort
äh, reden. So.
Ich glaube, das trifft, das trifft es eigentlich ganz
gut. So, next, nächstes, nächstes Thema.
Ähm,
ach ja, genau, habe ich sogar noch, habe ich ja sogar noch ein Beispiel
für. Ich habe,
ich habe sogar ein Beispiel für, habe ich mir aufgeschrieben.
Habe ich mir aufgeschrieben und zwar,
ähm,
es, es ging darum,
ich mache
da mal einen Beispielsatz draus, ja.
Also, stellt euch vor, stellt euch
vor, jemand sagt,
man hat Schwierigkeiten, Tickets zu finden,
weil die Nummer
sich nicht am Projekt orientiert,
sondern immer lange Random-IDs
generiert, also man kann sich die Tickets nicht merken, weil
das nur lange Random-IDs sind
und nicht das Projekt drinne steht.
So. Ich finde, relativ
klare Aussage, oder?
Aber, man kann natürlich
zehn Minuten darüber diskutieren,
dass es ja keine Tickets, sondern Service-Requests
sind.
Versteht ihr, was ich meine?
Wenn man sich auf die Essenz dieser Aussage
konzentrieren würde, ist es
scheißegal, ob es Tickets oder Service-Requests
sind. Es geht darum,
dass sich derjenige, egal ob Tickets oder
Service-Requests, sie sich nicht merken
kann, weil kein Projekt drinsteht.
Ja, versteht man, was ich meine?
Also, das ist halt auch so ein Ding,
das schreibe ich mir genau als Beispiel rein.
Das habe ich mir, als ich mir auch hier
gemeint ist.
Ja, das sind auch so Aussagen,
die dann im Zweifelsfall kommen können.
Ne, passt, das ist richtig.
So, das nächste ist,
ich glaube, da spreche ich
nicht an, dass wir
allgemein super unflexibel
sind, irgendwas zu machen. Ich habe vorgeschlagen,
wir könnten noch TMAX auf alle
unsere Server installieren.
Das war ein halber Weltuntergang
teilweise schon wieder,
weil man da an so vielen Stellen ja was machen
muss und da hat man unnötige Binarys
auf dem System und sowas. Alter, es geht um
TMAX, das ist 40 Kilobyte groß oder
so und ist enorm praktisch, wenn es halt einfach drauf ist.
Ja, aber das ist so ein Ding,
das hat mich nur persönlich aufgeregt.
Es ist eigentlich wurscht.
Ich kann es verstehen, dass man keinen Bock
hat, da so einen großen Aufriss zu machen.
Was das ist?
Das ist, ich kann es dir zeigen.
Wir gucken übrigens mal, wie groß das ist.
Oh shit!
Alter, ist das, ist das
etwa, ist das etwa 1 MB groß?
Bloated as fuck, man!
1,1 MB!
Ja, das geht nicht.
Das ist unmöglich.
Das kann man nicht machen.
Not possible.
Da ist die SSD voll.
Okay, next.
Nächstes Thema, das lassen wir weg.
Das nächste,
hatte ich schon halb AFK
während Meetings?
So, das elfte, sechste, äh nicht elfte,
sechster Punkt ist,
AskIquarium, beste.
Also, ähm,
nächster Punkt ist,
also seit mein Chef am Start ist,
hab ich mit dem, glaub ich, dreimal gesprochen.
Und
ich fänd's nice,
wenn man den mal ein bisschen
irgendwie öfters zu fassen
bekommt, ja.
Weil es gibt immer Chef
oft
selten, selten
greifbar.
Gibt immer mal kleine
Orgasachen zu
besprechen und so weiter.
Aber meistens
nicht wirklich, ja.
Das ist halt echt was,
ich weiß nicht,
was die den ganzen Tag machen, die Führungskräfte da,
aber, ich mein,
da gibt sich sichtlich Mühe,
indem er auch teilweise, wenn er schon weg ist,
in Teams antwortet und sowas.
Aber das ist ja auch für ihn kacke.
Ja.
Jaja, ne, kannst du vergessen.
Die sind, die sind oftmals
ganze, ganze Wochen
weg auf irgendwelchen, äh,
Führungskräftemaßnahmen und sowas.
Ey, haben wir nicht.
Das fänd ich, das fänd ich echt ganz
gut. Das, das, das fänd
ich echt ganz gut.
Äh, sagen wir mal, irgendwie, ja.
Einmal Woche, mindestens
einmal im Monat Chefs, irgendwie.
Damit man sich einfach
mal auslassen kann. Das, das wird echt was bringen.
Da kann man sich auch mal, wenn's
schlecht läuft, irgendwie ein Projekt drüber auskotzen,
ob der vielleicht noch eine Idee hat.
Oder wenn man irgendwas, was weiß ich,
irgendwie
sonst was nicht passt, oder, ne.
Es ist, es ist einfach besser.
Man, man kann regelmäßig
mal recht ungezwungen mit seinem Chef
schwätzen, anstatt dass man, anstatt dass er
dich ausm, ausm Feierabend
im, im Bus noch, im Zug mal
anrufen muss oder so, oder ausm Auto.
Das ist, das ist doof. Also,
das, das wird echt was bringen.
Ja, das wär nice.
So, siebtens. Ich glaub, wir
haben gar nicht mehr, das war's.
Ja, das war's.
Chat gibt, fertig.
Eine Stunde haben wir gebraucht.
Das ist ja noch nicht mal ne Seite.
Glaube, das, glaub das.
Ich muss mir grad noch mal kurz meine andere Sachen
durchlesen. Das brauchen wir nicht.
Okay.
Das kann weg.
Das kann auch weg. Okay, nice.
Excellent.
Okay, wie, wie, wie
kommst du da jetzt gerade drauf?
Äh, bislang gibt's ne Setup-Tour.
Es gibt, es gibt auf YouTube ein Video von meinem
Serverraum und
das war's.
Äh, ich glaube, es gibt,
hab ich, hab ich euch mal das
Raspberry Pi Setup im Keller gezeigt?
Nee, ich glaub, hab ich noch gar nicht gemacht.
Es gibt ein aktuelles
Video aus meinem Serverraum, aber ansonsten
gibt's da nicht,
hier gibt's auch nicht viel ans Setup zu sehen.
Ach ja, unten, unten Video über meinen neuen
PC gibt's auch.
Ja, also da muss ich sagen,
da bin ich, da bin ich mittlerweile schmerzlos,
was, was das angeht.
Also, ich hab mir vorgenommen,
damals, als ich noch beim, beim Provider
meine Ausbildung, also als, dort, wo ich meine Ausbildung
gemacht hab und da weg bin, da hab ich
oftmals Sachen, die
mich genervt haben, hab ich mich
nicht getraut, was dazu zu sagen oder ich
dachte mir, ey, wenn man, wenn
man das jetzt anspricht,
dann hat man da nur, hat man da nur Probleme
draus und so und da hab ich mir vorgenommen,
ey, wenn's Dinge
gibt,
die mir auf den Keks gehen, die
aber, sagen wir mal so, jetzt
nicht
so global galaktisch sind,
ja, wo ich dann sagen würde, ey,
das hat keinen Sinn,
dass ich einfach was zu sag.
Natürlich nur, wenn's nicht ganz zu nervig
wird, also,
wenn ich, ich wäge immer noch ab
dazwischen, macht es Sinn
was zu sagen, weil wenn du daraus
dann selbst nur Arbeit hast und das nix
bringt, dann kann man's auch gleich sein lassen.
Aber beispielsweise jetzt auf dem
Teambuilding irgendwie nicht ansprechen,
dass wir teilweise uns zu sehr
sidetracken lassen oder
zu sehr
uns über kleine Sachen
zu diskutieren,
selbst wenn's manchen Leuten nicht gefällt,
da müssen sie halt durch.
Ja, das versteh ich,
das find ich auch nicht gut.
Definiere mal bitte Sidetracking.
Hast du schon mal einen Stream von mir Sonntag
morgens gesehen?
Okay, anscheinend nicht, also,
Sidetracking ist,
ich versuch das jetzt mal irgendwie so für mich
für mich in Worte zu fassen ist,
wenn man eine Sache machen will
oder sich um eine Sache, genau,
der Stream ist ja Inbegriff von Sidetracking
bei mir Sonntags, wenn man, wenn man,
also bisschen off-topic quasi, ja,
also, wenn man zum Beispiel
sagt, ich guck mir jetzt
dieses Video an
und ich fange 10 Sekunden an zu gucken
und sag, ach, da fällt mir
ja auch noch was dazu ein und da und da und da
und dann redet man 15 Minuten über die,
über den ersten Satz in dem Video, so.
Man kommt halt so von einem Thema zum anderen
und kümmert sich nie um die eigentliche
Sache, um die es gehen sollte.
Ja, das stimmt.
Keck, geh.
Aber, C++
ist auch prinzipiell was, wo ich mich,
wo ich mich gerne drüber auslasse. Topic?
Äh, wir sind fertig.
Ich hab eine Liste erstellt,
Abschweifen, genau, Abschweifen.
Ist eine sehr gute Übersetzung für
Sidetracking. Da versteht man auch was Gemeinsames.
Ich hab morgen und übermorgen einen Teambuilding-Workshop
und hatte mir die letzten Wochen über
ein paar Sachen aufgeschrieben,
wo ich denke, dass man die verbessern
kann,
wo man zumindest drüber reden, drüber reden
könnte und jetzt habe ich versucht,
daraus mal eine Liste zu erstellen,
die man versteht.
Oh, Sixth Health.
Ja, Event, aber natürlich bezahltes Event.
Ich glaub nicht, dass ich da einfach so just for fun hingehe.
Aber wenn man
das schon hat, dann kann man ja,
also, ich hab keine Ahnung, wie dieses Event
wird. Vielleicht
ist es ja auch so ein, so ein,
ja, wie ich euch letztens erzählt
hab, wo wir gegen die Wand gespuckt haben im Teambuilding.
Vielleicht ist es auch sowas, wo so
die ganze Zeit irgendwelche blöden Teambuilding-Spielchen
gemacht werden. Da werde ich
mich dann zurückhalten und nur das Nötigste mitmachen.
Was? Du wirst nicht glauben,
hatte gestern eine Anfrage von einem
Kunden, der mir vorgegeben hat, was ich
ihm anbieten soll und auch wie ich es konfigurieren
soll.
Naja, also,
wenn der Kunde genaue
Vorstellungen hat, ist doch umso besser für dich, oder?
Da weißt du, dann ist
umso weniger offene Fragen, umso
besser. Da weißt du wenigstens, was der will
und du baust nicht was hin und am Ende
sagt er, ach nee, ich wollte doch was ganz anderes.
Wenn es natürlich schon in dem
Umfang ist, dass man sich fragen muss,
ey, warum macht das dann nicht selber, wenn
er alles im Detail schon so genau weiß?
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht, weil er keinen hat, der es kann.
Ja, wo ist das Problem?
Es ist, ey, es ist doch mal
zur Abwechslung gut, wenn die eine
genaue Vorstellung haben von dem, was sie haben
wollen.
Normalerweise ist das so, ist das eher so
wie auf diesem Bild mit der Schaukel.
Das kennt ihr doch alle. Warte mal, wie ist
das denn hier? Projekt,
Management, Schaukel.
Schaukel, das Bild. Hier, das da.
Normalerweise ist das doch so.
How the customer explain it,
how the project leader understood it,
how the analyst designed it.
Im Endeffekt,
what the customer really needed. Normalerweise ist es
doch so. Und wenn das
da und das da
möglichst nah beieinander liegen, ist doch umso besser,
oder? Ja.
Aber anscheinend wusste
er es in dem Fall doch. Ich meine,
vielleicht kannst du ja ein bisschen näher erzählen.
Also ich meine, in dem Fall wissen wir es
nicht, aber ich finde es immer prinzipiell gut,
wenn die Leute, die was haben wollen,
schon etwas
konkretere Vorstellungen haben,
als einfach nur, mach mal.
Er sagt, er will genau sechs Apps,
ach, Access Points, er will sechs
und die sollen genau da und da platziert werden.
Dann sehe ich, dass es von vorne
und hinten nicht geht.
Ach so, ja gut.
Das verstehe ich.
Ich denke, okay, das ist natürlich
was anderes, wenn er was, also wenn er darauf
besteht, dass du was technisch
Unsinniges machst.
Wenn ich das mal richtig
zusammengefasst habe,
da bleibt dir
im Endeffekt nichts übrig, wie zu
sagen, ey, weißt du was, ich baue hier nichts
halbfertiges, von dem ich eh weiß, dass es nicht geht.
Oder aber, du lässt dir
das halt exakt schriftlich
so in den Vertrag reinschreiben,
dass das so ist. Du kannst dich ja sogar
darauf hinweisen, dass du denkst, dass
das nicht die optimale Lösung
ist für ihn, aber wenn
er das so haben will, ich meine,
man muss sehen, wo man
bleibt. Er kann niemandem
davon abhalten, Scheiße zu kaufen.
Aber ich verstehe es schon, man
möchte ja, das kann ich schon nachvollziehen,
man möchte ja schon technisch
gut funktionierende und
saubere Lösungen hinbauen, anstatt
irgendwas Hingewurschteltes.
Er gibt mir auch
die, dann hat er gelitten.
Also entweder willst du es zu dem Preis machen oder nicht,
wahrscheinlich nicht, dann hat er halt Pech.
Dann hat er gelitten.
Also wenn er anfängt, so nach dem Motto, ich will
exakt das und das, es darf aber nicht
mehr als das kosten und du denkst dir, Alter, dafür geht's nicht.
Kann ich, kann ich noch nicht mal
kann ich noch nicht mal
irgendwie, bin ich noch nicht mal aufgestanden
und hingefahren, so, dann
dann nicht, ja.
Das hier beschreibt es ganz gut.
Ja.
Genau so ist es im Endeffekt.
Für den Preis
kriegt ja nicht mal ich den bei Amazon.
Geschweige denn von Einbau,
Aufbau
und allem drum herum.
Ja.
Dann hat er halt Pech.
Dann hat er halt gelitten, dann gibt's halt nix.
So Chat, also, wir haben das ja
heute wunderbar hingekriegt.
Haben wir noch irgendein Video, was wir uns angucken können,
so jetzt, so die letzten
45 Minuten? Achso,
ich sollte mir das hier erstmal
rüberkopieren, dass ich das dann
nachher ausdrucken kann.
Fireship!
Ja, können wir tatsächlich machen.
Düdüdüdüdüdüdü.
Fireship können wir tatsächlich gucken.
Aber haben wir noch irgendwas anderes?
Ach, was der Lindner macht, interessiert mich jetzt, ehrlich gesagt, überhaupt nicht.
Desktop-Environment-Tierlist!
Oh, ne,
nicht nochmal, nicht nochmal!
Ist da i3 dabei?
Ich mein, i3 ist kein Desktop-Environment,
aber, seriously,
i3-Beste.
Die schreckliche NFT-Hölle
des Black-and-White-Erfinders.
Ach, hat, hat,
hat Peter mal wieder
ein neues Scam-Game
rausgehauen, so nach den letzten
irgendwie gefühlten fünf
Dingern, die er rausgebracht hat
und nie weiterentwickelt hat.
Haben wir denn sonst noch?
Äh, what?
OKS?
Das haben wir doch schon geguckt.
Das haben wir auch schon geguckt.
Das haben wir nicht geguckt.
So, YouTube, was gibt's hier so als Empfehlung?
Der große
Vertrauensbruch!
Das halten die Deutschen von ihrer Regierung.
Aktuell, glaube ich, halten
sehr viele nichts davon.
Ich halte eigentlich schon
die ganzen letzten Jahre
und inklusive jetzt
nichts davon.
Aber gut.
Man hat ja wenig Einfluss drauf,
außer ab und zu mal wählen zu gehen.
The most epic GitHub
Pull-Request.
OK, Fireship. Was, was hat Fireship
am Start? Hier!
Oh, ne.
OpenAI-Drama hab ich keinen Bock.
YouTube Adblock Wars.
OK, das können wir mal gucken.
Fireship ist immer nice.
Kannst du den Anfang von dem 37-Minuten-Video schauen?
Das da?
Harder Drive.
Um was geht's da überhaupt?
Ich mach das mal zu.
Ja, ich hab tatsächlich in Hessen
auch wieder die FDP gewählt.
Der Markt regelt das.
Keck, wait.
Komm, wir gucken jetzt erst mal Fireship.
Und danach gucken wir vielleicht...
Das andere weiß ich nicht. Irgendwie spricht mich das
nicht so an.
Das sieht ein bisschen nach Cocker aus.
Also Fireship, let's go!
Fireship hat lange nichts hochgeladen.
You may not realize it,
but we're in the middle of a high-stakes war.
Not in the Middle East, but right here in your browser.
Hey, Cod 4
Gameplay.
While staring at this
magic glowing screen.
It is November 24th, 2023
and you're watching The Code Report.
Back in June 2023, a small group of YouTube users
were surprised to get this message,
cutting them off for having an ad blocker enabled.
Making them the first casualties of YouTube's
ad blocker blocker.
Because you're just a material girl living in a material world,
your attention is very valuable.
It only takes a few seconds for a good advertisement
to inject some information into your hippocampus,
where it can then be transferred to the frontal lobe
to manipulate your impulse control
that you don't need.
By the way guys, Black Friday Cyber Monday Sale
Fireship Pro 40%
Ach, heute ist ja Cyber Monday, ja.
Habt ihr irgendwas gekauft jetzt bei dieser ganzen Black Friday Cyber Monday Geschichte?
Ich hab was gekauft,
aber nicht explizit im Black Friday,
sondern einfach, weil ich's gebraucht hab.
Ich hab mir noch zwei Paare
so neon-gelbe Socken
zum Rennen gekauft.
Das ist eine gute Frage,
da kann ich was zu sagen.
Chat, ich lass mich kurz sidetracken, alles klar?
Sie schatten mit .NET
Contained oder Golang für Cross-Platform-CLI
will mir ein kleines Pomodoro bauen.
Also unabhängig davon, was du dir bauen willst,
ist es wahrscheinlich ein
Command Line Tool.
Steht ja auch da.
Und dazu kannst du
beides verwenden, was dir lieber ist.
Ich persönlich mag .NET
lieber, Go ist aber auch super.
Was in Go halt
total easy ist, ist tatsächlich
Cross-Platform und
möglichst lang rückwärts kompatibel,
aber
mit .NET 8 ist das
in .NET selbst auch deutlich
besser geworden. Und ich würde gar nicht
.NET Self-Contained nehmen, sondern
ich würde .NET
Ahead of Time kompiliert nehmen.
Und dann kompilierst du das Ganze
in einem
Docker-Container, zum Beispiel
mit Ubuntu 16.04
und dann
bekommst du ein Self-Contained
Native Binary raus,
was lauffähig ist auf allen Linux-Distributionen
der letzten 10 Jahre.
Ja gut, ja doch, fast.
Oder 14.04
kann man glaube ich sogar noch nehmen.
Also, Go kann das
out of the box, weil Go halt
keinerlei Systemabhängigkeiten bundelt
oder
voraussetzt. C-Sharp
hat auch mit
Ahead of Time Compilation so gut wie
keine Systemvoraussetzungen, allerdings
haben die aus irgendwelchen
Gründen die aktuellen
libc-Versionen
als
Requirement drin von dem System,
wo man es drauf kompiliert hat.
Das heißt, wenn du es in einem ollen Docker-Container
kompilierst, hast du auch ein Binary,
was rückwirkend lauffähig ist auf
allen Linux der letzten 10 Jahre.
Also im Prinzip, du kannst es mit
beidem ziemlich gut machen, wenn es
Command-Line, Self-Contained, Cross-Platform,
Applications sein sollen.
Und wenn du Minus-Minus-Self-Contained
nimmst, kannst du das Ganze auch sein lassen, weil
dann
benutzt er das offizielle
.NET Runtime
und die wurde glaube ich
gebaut auf einem
oder mit Libraries von
Ubuntu 14.04 oder sowas.
Ist also auch lange rückwirkend.
Windows, Ubuntu bzw. Docker Desktop
Achso, wenn du unter Windows bist, vergiss es.
Dann nimm lieber Go.
Wenn du unter Windows entwickelst
und Cross-Platform für Linux und Windows
machen willst, keine Ahnung.
Docker und
Windows ist mir einfach sehr sus.
Äh.
Dann nimm lieber Docker.
Dann nimm lieber Go.
Wenn du
easy Cross-Platform und rückwärts
kompatible Binaries brauchst,
dann nimm Go.
Wenn du kein ordentlich
funktionierendes Docker hast und unter
Windows bist, dann nimm lieber Go.
Okay, Fireship weiter gucken.
Leicht zeitgetrackt.
Das ist ja fast nix.
Das ist heftig, oder?
Das ist richtig heftig.
Ich hätte eigentlich gedacht, dass bei
Google der Anteil
von Cloud
auch höher ist mittlerweile.
Bei Microsoft ist ja quasi
die Anzahl von Clouds
auch höher.
Bei Microsoft ist ja quasi
die Anzahl von Clouds
auch höher ist mittlerweile.
Bei Microsoft ist ja quasi
Cloud-Services die Hälfte
von dem, was sie verdienen.
Stimmt, was macht...
Lass mich mal kurz gucken.
Was macht mein ETF eigentlich?
Stonks. Sekunde, was macht
mein ETF?
Lass mich mal kurz checken.
Okay, Stonks sind wieder
hochgegangen. Nice.
Stonks sind wieder ein bisschen gestiegen die letzte Woche.
Ich habe die Anzahl von Clouds
auf YouTube übernommen.
Das ist die zweitgrößte
weltweit populärste Website,
aber Plattformen wie Facebook und Instagram
machen einen viel besseren Job,
Anzahl von Clouds zu generieren.
YouTube ist auch sehr teuer.
Streamen mit niedriger Latenz
braucht riesige Datenzentren mit CDNs
überall auf der Welt.
YouTube ist ein technologischer
Marvel und sie bieten alles gratis
in Bezug auf die Privatität
und die Realität in deinem Gehirn.
Es gibt viele Videos, die
über deine Browsing-Historie,
Location und Demografik
zeigen, um dir targette Advertisements zu zeigen.
Und das ist ziemlich schrecklich.
Das ist das philosophische Argument.
Aber meistens sind Ads nur furchtbar.
Und wir sollten die Freiheit haben,
sie zu nutzen.
Es gibt sehr viele Werbungen,
die schon abgefuckt sind.
Viele haben schon angefangen.
Und es gab noch Werbungen,
die schädlich für dich waren.
Von Flash-Werbungen,
von Flash- und Java-Applet-Werbungen,
was es früher nicht alles für ein Shit gab.
Wo du im Zweifelsfall noch Viren
auf deinem Rechner einfangen konntest
oder einfach nur deinen Browser
gefreestest oder was auch immer.
Und spätestens da haben die Leute gesagt,
nope, Adblocker.
Also, wir können nicht
die Internet-Anlage nutzen,
die wir wollen.
Aber als Content-Creator
könnte ich sagen,
dass Adblock Zerstörung ist.
Wenn du eine Ad-Ad-Adresse schaust,
geht 55% zu mir,
und die anderen 45% zu dem großen Mann.
Aber wenn jemand in den Chrome-Webstore
kommt und Ublock Origin installiert,
ein open source Chrome-Plugin
von 34 Millionen anderen Menschen,
dann hat es eine Art von Technik,
Ads auf Webseiten und YouTube zu blockieren.
Wenn es installiert ist,
kannst du es testen,
um sicherzustellen, dass es funktioniert
auf Webseiten wie adblocktester.com.
Und weil es alles open source ist,
kannst du sehen, wie alles funktioniert
in diesem Code hier auf GitHub.
Aber jetzt bist du ein blöder Pirat,
der von ehrlichen Creatoren steuert,
wie Logan Paul und SS-Sniperwolf.
Und wenn du immer Dinge installierst,
wie Adblock, Adblock Plus,
Adguard, Ghostery, Ublock Origin,
Adblocker Ultimate,
und so weiter, dann hast du
eine Art Adblocker-Premium.
Und es teilt Revenue aus diesem Produkt
mit YouTube-Creatoren.
Das heißt, YouTube hat
nicht so viel abbekommen,
wie sie könnten.
Ich bin mir auch gar nicht sicher,
ob es Statistiken dazu gibt,
wie es so mit Einnahmen und Ausgaben
bei YouTube aussieht.
Also ich weiß, dass YouTube lange Zeit
keine Kohle abgeworfen hat.
Mittlerweile ja anscheinend schon.
Aber ich bin mal gespannt.
Ich glaube nicht, dass YouTube
das auf Dauer gewinnen kann.
Man könnte jetzt auch sagen,
hey, die Adblocker
können das auf Dauer gewinnen,
weil YouTube hat ja viel
einfachere Möglichkeiten,
was zu ändern.
Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen,
dass das YouTube nicht auf Dauer
gewinnen kann.
Weil entweder es normale User
irgendwann so krass abfuckt alles
und sie abhauen
und sich halt nicht mehr geben
und lieber Twitch gucken oder so.
Die müssen halt, die versuchen halt
die Balance zu finden.
Gerade.
Ich nehme gerade noch mit,
dass wir noch Maximum an Kohle kriegen.
Das ist der Test gerade.
Ich habe auch YouTube Premium.
Die verabschieden sich aus dem Internet.
Aber anstattdessen haben sie gewohnt
und gewonnen haben.
Gadget abfangen ist ein Hinweis,
dass die Videobelastung auf den Adblocker
produziert wird,
wenn du den Adblocker nicht abfüllst.
In der Beziehung wird die gesamte Erfahrung
für die Adblocker-Aufnahme
wahrscheinlich in der Zukunft schlimmer.
Bald braucht man den Adblocker,
Adblockerkennungsentfernungs-Adblocker.
Erkennungs-Entfernungs-Adblocker.
Also sowas gibt's ja schon.
... Chrome-Extension, you have to have a manifest.json-file.
This file defines what the extension is allowed to do on the...
Da hatte ich's doch letztens von, wo man wieder gesehen hat,
dass es doch nicht so gut ist, wenn die Macht alles bei einer Firma liegt, ja?
Plattformbetreiber und Browser-Anbieter in einem.
Da kannst du halt sowas machen wie, Moment, alle, die unseren Browser verwenden,
die können halt einfach keinen Adblock mehr benutzen.
Ja, ja, sagt alles vorbei, ja, Pech gehabt.
Die rudern dann nur immer wieder zurück, weil der Aufschrei noch groß genug ist.
Die probieren das immer wieder, bis der Aufschrei nicht mal groß genug ist.
Glücklicherweise, wir können echt froh sein, dass es Firefox gibt.
Da sieht man, dass es echt wichtig ist,
bei solcher essentiellen Software wie Webbrowser Alternativen zu haben.
... that it's using Manifest Version 2.
Then if we go down to Permissions, you'll notice it's using WebRequest
...
... and WebRequest blocking.
These APIs made it easy for an extension to intercept a network request,
and then modify it so it can't display the ad it wants to.
Now, the thing is, Manifest Version 2 is being deprecated in favor of Version 3,
which replaces the WebRequest API with the declarative NetRequest API,
which is far more limited when it comes to dynamically filtering content.
What's kind of funny is that Chrome actually might need AdBlockers,
because as recently as last Christmas, the FBI was recommending people install them
to protect against malicious advertisements hosting ransomware.
Ultimately, I do think it's true.
I think it's possible that YouTube could eradicate AdBlockers altogether.
But currently, it's a lot like when Barbra Streisand tried to suppress a photo of her house
that almost nobody knew about, resulting in the opposite intended effect,
making the photo extremely famous.
We're currently seeing the Streisand effect with AdBlockers,
where more and more people are learning about them
and using them despite the fact that they violate the terms of service.
It's also making the AdBlockers become more sophisticated.
It's only a matter of time before someone invents an AdBlocker-Blocker-Blocker
that can block this AdBlocker.
Das gibt es schon. Das gibt es ja schon.
... Blocker-Blocker.
Es wird YouTube geäußert, um dann sein eigenes AdBlocker-Blocker-Blocker-Blocker zu inventieren,
an dem Punkt wird dieses Lied zu repetitiv.
Das war der Code-Report. Danke fürs Zuschauen.
Was zum Teufel bin ich da auf der rechten Seite sehend?
... und ich werde dich in der nächsten sehen.
leute
...
das ist halt immer das siehst du schon auch als normalsterblicher wenn du post vom finanzamt
kriegst das besteht aus der halben seite mit dingern die du machen sollst und dann sieben
seiten rechtsbelehrung was passiert wenn du es nicht machst ich schaue mir den anfang vom video
an ok weil ico weil du es bist ich schaue mir jetzt den anfang von deinem video an was du
geschickt hast wie lang wann ist der anfang vorbei bei 36 minuten erste minute okay chainsaws big
problem right you can only hold two chainsaws at a time a configuration known as dual wield
an enterprising person could probably manage to put a few more chainsaws on
their body maybe in a one-man-band kind of kind das ist mir zu hell duration with
foot saws and knee activated saws
and a harmonica saw and head saw i think maybe this one would have to be duct taped on
and while we're at it we probably should add some night vision goggles technical but the records
for most chainsaws simultaneously brandished were all set by a different technique which is juggling
now you might think that you can equip an arbitrary number of chainsaws by juggling
them higher and higher into the air a configuration known as infinity wield
was sind für sind
dann
das video was ico geschickt hat ich weiß auch noch nicht so genau
but unfortunately once you juggle them high enough you have to throw them fast enough that they exceed the escape velocity of eleven thousand kilometers per second
and then instead of coming back to you they just go off into space
but you know we're not limited to throwing these things straight up we could also throw them tangent to the earth
shy of the escape velocity and this will create an orbit where they'll go around the earth and come back and land in our other hand
which is very convenient for juggling
here's a computer simulation of that
we can of course ignore air resistance since chainsaws will cut through the air like butter
we get a nice elliptical orbit
and of course we could pack many chainsaws into this
was hältst du von blaulichtfilterbrillen
ich hab selbst mal eine benutzt eine zeit lang
eine gunner optics brille
die das ganze so gelblich gemacht hat
aber nutze ich nicht mehr
at the same time
let's see if we can catch it
oh well
pretty close
was sind wir hier sehend leude
so now we've got these saws shooting by at eleven thousand kilometers a second
and we catch and launch them back into orbit
the saws can be efficiently packed in this nice arrangement
and so really what's gonna limit us is the volume of chainsaws that we can fit into this reachable area for juggling
so in this volume we'll see
hi hi cute zeugs bis jetzt ist es sehr wirr
about fifty five thousand three hundred ninety saws
per second
and since one orbit takes three hundred thirty five point six hours
we'll have that long before we see a saw a second time
thus we're simultaneously brandishing
one point two one five times ten to the twelve saws
this is a configuration known as terra wield
now i don't have any chainsaws
i live in the city where i have two trees
and if i cut those down i'm done
so there'll be none of that
but we could consider juggling with something that's even more dangerous
radio waves below forty megahertz actually bounce off the upper atmosphere
and they could do this multiple times
in principle we could make it all the way around the world
we only need to talk about principles here
because we're obviously not gonna do this
but if you did
the circumference of the earth is about forty thousand kilometers
which means that it'll take at least a hundred and fifty milliseconds
at the speed of light
for radio waves
to make their way around the earth this way
there's so much time
i calculated it in the fucking video
and people still said it's not true
instead of using radio waves
let's just use internet waves
it turns out that there are computers all around the internet
that will send a message back to you
if you send them a message
this message is called icmp echo
to which they'll send an icmp echo reply
okay okay
ich bin immerhin
das muss ich sagen
das ist ganz selten
dass die leute ping mal korrekt bezeichnen
icmp echo request
request icmp echo reply
and that message basically consists of a packet that says
what your source ip address is
and where you're sending it
the destination ip
and there's a payload
some freeform data
which gets returned as is
so i send one of these packets to australia
with my return address on it
and some data that i want to quote unquote store
then i can discard that data
and when it comes back
i can read it
and i could do this
to a bunch of hosts around the world
on the internet
and in doing so store a significant
let's see
amount of data in the internet
so let's do that
and not just that
ich glaube ich weiß worauf er raus will
er will daten quasi in seinem ping verstecken
und er rechnet jetzt wahrscheinlich aus
wie viel pings er losschicken muss
dass er seine daten quasi in transit
safen kann
so irgendwie was in der richtung
kommt jetzt wahrscheinlich
this is the true story of hard drives
we didn't want or need
it's called harder drive
by the way this icmp echo thing
is also known as a ping
so i put together some code
to send out a lot of pings
and while i was doing that
können wir für solche fälle
brauche ich irgendwie ein halbtransparentes
schwarzes fenster
was ich drüber machen kann
and i figured
why not ping the whole internet
so i did
by internet here i mean the ipv4 address space
which are addresses that you know and love
like a.b.c.d
each of which can go from 0 to 255
those are 8 bits
so together we have 32 bits
or 4.2 billion addresses
now i don't care about ipv6
there's way too many addresses
and most of them aren't used
plus like call me when you're at least version 7
am i right?
ipv4 is great
and 4.2 billion isn't that big of a number anymore
with my home internet which is advertised as
1 gigabit per second
i should be able to finish in about 20 minutes
or you know a couple hours
or most a week
well it turns out that sending this many pings
was hell on my home network
and not only does it end up dropping a lot of the pings
so it's useless
it renders the whole network completely unusable
which is definitely a no-no
for the work from home lifestyle
and i was really only able to push this to about
1000 pings per second
which is nothing
it could be that my isp is throttling me
or there's NAT tables which aren't big enough
to handle this many different addresses
or ddos protection
or i'm just bad at this
who knows
in any case i ended up renting some time on some servers
and some clusters
so that i could finish the job
because the best excuse is that you just freaking did it
so i finished it up
and now we can look
so ganz check ich immer noch nicht so genau
worauf er raus will
weil
selbst wenn du deine daten quasi permanent im internet hast
weil du sie permanent immer quasi in pings rumschicken
du brauchst die daten ja weiterhin
dass du deine pings ab und zu refreshen kannst
oder baut er jetzt irgendwie so eine art mesh network
dass die dann irgendwie keine ahnung
okay
the whole internet
so here is the internet
let me zoom in a little bit
actually let me zoom in a lot
here we have every ip address on the internet
you can see them at the bottom left
and the dot will be white if it responded to my ping
and black if not
okay
and here i've arranged the ip addresses using a hilbert curve
which is a sort of fractal space filling curve
it looks like this
which is a standard way to do this
this is not a video about the hilbert curve
it's not even a video about pinging the internet
there are some somewhat interesting parts here
so this white block here always responded to my pings
that's because it's the loopback address 127 dot star
which is basically my local computer
so it always responds to that
up here are a bunch of reserved or multicast addresses
so it makes sense that none of those ever responded
throughout the rest we can see a lot of different characters
so i'll just give you a bit of a tour
depending on how this address space has been allocated
and each of these corresponds to a different network
which is broken into sub networks
this one has fairly fine-grained divisions
this reminds me of a farmland allocation in the united states
schon so ein bisschen
that's that square
over here we see a network that is very likely to respond to your ping
although there are some blackout regions
this area has all sorts of patterns
ja okay
das müssen wir uns jetzt nicht im detail angucken
wie das ganze internet auf pings antwortet
we've got some stuff you could print on a tie
we've got some mazes
we've got some tetris pieces
maybe even some letters here
we've got a crossword puzzle
and by the way this way of mapping the internet is basically canonical
and it wouldn't be that hard to embed some kind of picture or message in here
like how cool would it be to embed a little qr code in this right
like it would be a little bit cool
maybe a little embarrassing too
anyway that's the internet
probably somewhere in here is your computer too
und jetzt möchte ich es bauen
unser erstes virtuelles Hard Drive
mit dem was wir gelernt haben
das ist im Grunde ein Laudatio
in Unix sind Schattsysteme abstraktiert
als Quote-unquote Block Geräte
die Quote-unquote nur File sind
eine Art Blockgerät zu machen wäre
ein Kernmodul zu implementieren
aber dann würde ich viel Rebooting machen
NBD Kit, der für Laudatio steht
ist eine Bibliothek für die Erstellung von Netzwerkblockgeräten in der User Space
in der Userspace, die man für ernsthafte Anwendungen oder für dumme Anwendungen wie heute verwenden kann.
Um ein Gerät zu implementieren, muss man eine Funktion wie READ implementieren,
die eine Adresse in der Länge nimmt und die Daten, die an dieser Adresse sind, zurückgibt.
Und WRITE macht das Gegenteil.
Sobald du eines dieser virtuellen Geräte machst, kannst du es auf dem System montieren,
du kannst es mit einem Filesystem formaten und dann kannst du File aufnehmen.
Das kleinste Block-Gerät, das ich nutzen kann, ist 51.200 Byte.
Um das zu machen, muss ich das FAT12-Filesystem nutzen,
welches aus der DOS-Ära ist,
das für 5 ¼-Inch-Floppy-Drives verwendet wird.
Was wir also tun, ist ein Gerät zu machen, das 100 512 Byte-Blocken hat.
Jede dieser Blocken wird von einem Niveau ausstehender Pings gespeichert.
Und ich werde mehrere Pings pro Block für Redundanz verwenden.
Ja, aber der braucht die Daten doch trotzdem noch,
damit er die Pings immer wieder los schicken kann.
Oder wie soll das funktionieren?
Ich will meine Daten nicht verlieren.
Nun, trotz der Tatsache, dass ich die gesamte Internetseite bereits gespeichert habe,
habe ich die Liste dieser Hosts per Hand geschaffen.
Und eine der Gründe dafür ist, dass ich wollte,
dass ich nicht jemandem ein Telefon auf einer meterischen Verbindung schlagen würde.
Aber ich will auch Hosts, die geografisch divers sind,
denn ich will keine korrelierten Fehler.
Und ich will, dass sie hochwertig sind.
Ich will, dass sie auf meine 512 Byte-Pings beantworten,
fast jederzeit.
Aber ich will auch,
dass sie langsam sind.
Und das ist eine seltsame Kombination, oder?
Normalerweise will ich, dass sie schnell und aufmerksam sind.
Hier will ich, dass sie langsam und aufmerksam sind.
2.
1.
process their request and rights have a similar challenge the biggest problem here is the
aforementioned throttling to about a thousand pings a second i barely got this okay dann
ich frag mich wo er das in seinem ping package stort dass die antwort darauf dass die daten
wieder enthält weiß ich nicht was man dafür missbrauchen kann bei so einem icmp paket
it's working but it would have been nice if i could send a few million pings per second instead
of one thousand i also built a ui for this thing which we'll see in a second so now what i want
to do is stand up the drive and i want to benchmark it to see how well it performs in order to do that
i need to figure out what data i want to store on this drive so i decided a fitting file one that is
a kind of improper hierarchy would be rfc 792 a text file that describes the internet control
message protocol icmp echo and echo reply that we're using that thing is 30 kilobytes so it
just barely fits on the drive
so here it is running that benchmark uh the white blocks are healthy blocks those are blocks where
we have the full target number of pings outstanding if a block isn't white that means we've lost a
ping and then it's in danger of failing and that will happen all of the time the crossed out blocks
have not yet been written so they don't have any data the red dot indicates a block with an
outstanding
a right so you'll see that move around as the benchmark goes and a green block the same for
reading at the bottom you can see some of the hosts and statistics i keep track of the statistics on
the host so that i don't overload one host and if it comes less reliable or too fast then i try to
avoid using it after the benchmark finishes i guess there's a hiccup in the system or something
and i actually do lose some data so a couple of these blocks die and don't come back
that will happen this is not a reliable way of storing data but we can look at the file that i
stored and read that protocol description uh you'll see right here there's an area that was lost
that's all zeros now but the benchmark did completely so we can get some numbers but i
don't just want to evaluate these drives by their speed let's also consider the qualitative aspect
qualitatively this is a pretty good harder drive
it does solve a problem that we don't have which is to pretend we have a fast network but no memory
in which to store data it treats latency as a desirable quantity contrary to the usual preference
and it was harder to make than i expected the cost is not too bad i have to have a computer
but i always have to have a computer my home network costs about eighty dollars a month
for one quote unquote gigabit and this is about as much as i can store before the thing fails
this ends up being about zero point one five cents per byte per month which is not too bad
longevity however is das ist ganz schön viel cents per byte per month which is not too bad
this is that 0.1 cent per byte
this is glaube ich weiß nicht ob das wirklich das erscheint mir jetzt ziemlich viel
10 byte
also 8 byte hast du dann einen cent
ich habe also das weiß nicht das scheint mir nicht billig zu sein longevity however is poor
the benchmark succeeds with 100 with 100 accuracy like i mentioned but the data is lost readily if
you leave it running for a few minutes and since we store the data externally using untrusted hosts
they can just send back also mich würde ja immer noch interessieren wie er das jetzt genau macht
weil ich dachte eigentlich immer dass
was du in einem ping du kannst das war zeug reinschreiben an daten aber das was zurückkommt
muss ja nicht zwangsläufig deine nicht wirklich ping relevanten sachen enthalten noch
oder doch ich habe keine ahnung they want and corrupt the drive on the other hand since we
don't store any data locally we could consider this non-volatile storage in the sense that if
we completely lose power the data still exists as long as we can re-upload the data and we can
reboot in about a hundred milliseconds uh to receive the pings as they arrive
which is kind of unlikely the speed is pretty slow i got about fourteen kilobytes
a second reading you're writing yeahide aber die seiten basically the same operation
power consumption for me is low but the internet itself actually uses a lot of power
a typical undersee cable is excited with power on the order of tens of kilowatts and they have
repeaters every hundred kilometers or so so
kilometers or so which is a lot of power there's a lot of juice if i was the only one using this
it would be very very inefficient fortunately many people are using the internet and these
pings are a tiny fraction of the bandwidth and if i assume that my internet bill covers the
marginal cost of the power for the internet which makes sense um then it turns out to be about 5.8
micro watts micro watts in terms of harm to society the drive is definitely harmful to my
home network whether you can consider that a positive or negative to society is left as an
exercise to the reader at this scale it's a trivial impact on the internet at large but if
we were to do this to store many terabytes of data or if everyone were doing this it would be pretty
bad for the shared infrastructure and we're kind of freeloading off the willingness of other hosts
to respond uh to our ping ja und wo gibt es jetzt die details außer ja speaking of antisocial
antisocial
i'm sorry to remind you about vladimir putins illegal invasion of ukraine but this section
concerns a hard drive made from soviet blocks and when i say that of course i mean tetris
tetris is an inventory management survival horror game from the soviet union in 1984
it features 19 principal characters which are these and like all living things they're made up of
pixels or blocks so we can make a block device out of these the tetris playfield is 10 squares wide
and is this it's honestly x a tema cake next but to tune das schon das nächste thema oder das ist
irgendwie daten storage in tetris da scheint so scheint so okay das reicht mir ja wir wissen nicht
dass wir sachen in pink storen können alles klar irgendwie war mir das indirekt vorher schon klar
nur habe ich den sinn davon also ich war nicht klar dass man da sowas draus alter schon wieder
update dass man da sowas draus bauen kann weil wir rebooten noch mal beim ersten reboot so chat
aber es noch fünf minuten zeit gibt es doch irgendwas wichtiges was wir unbedingt heute
noch besprechen müssen ja ganz bestimmt er mich irritiert mit die anzeige desktop 1 desktop 2 die
ist neu gibt es noch nicht so lang als der sinn des lebens möglichst viel das zu machen worauf
man bock hat so suspend
wenn sonst nichts mehr gibt dann sehen wir uns morgen nicht morgen bin ich auf meinem
team building workshop sondern wir sehen uns am mittwoch wahrscheinlich wieder der hentai
watcher ist auch im namen aller jahre jetzt bestimmt also wir sehen uns bis denn sie beten
freie time
genug fertig bis denn zu